aufregung um die aussage des
ukrainischen botschafters andrej melik
verlieren die ukraine wirklich die lust
auf deutschland fühlen sie sich bei uns
hier nicht willkommen genau so stellt
sie wenig dass bei unserem politik die
richtigen fragen in den raum
hunderttausende ukrainer viele märz und
april vor putins angriffskrieg nach
deutschland und zogen bei uns sicherheit
und schutz jetzt stellt sich die frage
wie wurden diese flüchtlinge in
deutschland aufgenommen wurden sie mit
offenen armen empfangen fühlen sie sich
hier wohl nein sagt jetzt der
ukrainische botschafter in deutschland
andrej melik die meisten ukrainer kehren
zurück schon längst es sind mehr
menschen die abreise aus diesem land die
zu ihnen kommen und ich glaube dass sie
sich auch gedanken machen sollten über
die gründe wenn ich jetzt diese runde
mal mir anhöre ich glaube das ist auch
klar wie viele ukrainer wieso sie keine
lust haben hierzubleiben
sie fühlen sich nicht viel raum nein
wir wollen es natürlich auch ukrainische
flüchtlinge gefragt fühlen sie sich
nicht wohl hier bei uns in deutschland
fühle mich in deutschland willkommen
viele leute haben wir bei all meinen
fragen geholfen ich fühle mich sicherer
als in der ukraine
ich möchte zurück in die ukraine wenn
der krieg vorbei ist ich lese viel
darüber und informiere mich bei frauen
die noch in der ukraine sind die russen
bombardieren uns weiterhin mit
artillerie im augenblick muss ich mich
von der ukraine fernhalten meine wohnung
ist gut für jetzt aber nicht für immer
die müllcontainer sind verschimmelt ich
rieche die zigaretten der nachbarn es
ist zu laut ich kann mich nicht
entspannen ich liebe außerdem in einer
gefährlichen gegend im dunklen habe ich
angst draußen
und bei uns im studio ist jetzt ralf
schuler leiter der parlamentsredaktion
hierbei bildschirm es bei uns bisher
versorgen mit diesem satz dass sich
viele ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht
willkommen fühlen bei uns in deutschland
hat der botschafter damit auch der
ukraine einen gefallen getan ich glaube
nicht der botschafter hat ja einen ganz
speziellen stil das haben wir schon
mehrfach mitbekommen hat ja auch den
bundeskanzler man als beleidigte
leberwurst bezeichnet nicht gerade
diplomatisch ist eigentlich eher um
diplomatische diplomat den wir kennen
trotzdem schießt er halt manchmal über
das ziel hinaus und ich glaube in dem
fall ganz deutlich es gibt seit jahren
eine feste laufende ukraine hilfe auch
vor dem krieg schon in lobetal berlin
aber auch in vielen anderen städten
jetzt zu pfingsten zu ostern gab es
gemeinden überall im land die
ukrainische flüchtlinge aufgenommen
haben sich mit ihm getroffen haben es
gab kaffee trinken also es gibt da eine
vielzahl von aktivitäten ich weiß nicht
aus welchen quellen er diese
unzufriedenheit
gemessen haben will und wie breit er
wirklich da die datenbasis hat ich kann
das nicht beobachten wir können es
eigentlich auch nicht beobachten es gab
zu anfang das organisationschaos in
berlin berlin ist insgesamt ein failed
state das wissen wir alle inzwischen hat
sich das eingerenkt also eine breite
ablehnung kann ich nicht erkennen wenn
wir mal mit 20 15 vergleichen dann ist
die stimmung im land eine ganz andere
und wir haben in den 90er jahren die
älteren wie ich leider erinnern sich
eine ähnliche situation gehabt mit
bosnischen flüchtlingen die auch alle
von anfang an gesagt haben ja aber wir
wollen sofort in unser land zurück das
ist kein ausweis von misstrauen oder
ablehnung es ist einfach eine gesunde
liebe zur eigenen nation sehen wir jetzt
wieder der botschafter bezog sich ja vor
allem in diesem tag auch darauf dass die
menschen die ukraine hier bei uns in
deutschland vielleicht auch ein bisschen
enttäuscht darüber sind dass deutschland
immer noch keine schweren waffen liefert
und aus diesen gründen vielleicht sagen
gefühlen uns hier nicht wo wir fühlen
uns willkommen wir gehen lieber zurück
in die heimat jetzt ist es ja so dass
olaf scholz angekündigt hat auch endlich
muss man sagen in die ukraine zu reisen
mittrage und man kommt zusammen in den
nächsten tagen und weiß nicht genau wann
es stattfinden wird aus
sicherheitsgründen was erwartest du von
diesem besuch was hat das für eine
signalwirkung er kann nicht mit leeren
händen kommt immer gesagt ich will nicht
nur in reisen für ein foto wie es
vielleicht andere gemacht haben was wird
es gibt in der tat den eindruck dass
olaf scholz zwar angekündigt aber wenn
es dann um reale lieferung geht doch
ganz stark verzögert aus welchen gründen
auch immer darüber gibt es spekulationen
der besuch ist jedenfalls ein großes
zeichen zusammen mit max zusammen mit
drang in den großen volkswirtschaften
europas sich da auf den weg zu machen es
ist auch ein zeichen dass man nicht
einfach der protokollarischen
anforderungen aus kiel folgt also soll
jetzt endlich mal kommen und dann beugt
sich selbstverständlich der deutsche
kanzler und fährt hin nein sie haben ein
protokollarischer größeres event daraus
gemacht und sie fahren dahin um einfach
zu zeigen wir stehen an der seite
europas der ukraine und europa wird
mutmaßlich am freitag auch bei diesem
besuch klar machen dass die ukraine zu
europa gehört das ist eine
beitrittsperspektive gibt die ist lang
aber ein ganz klares zeichen die ukraine
kann in die europäische union kommen das
sind weiter weg das wird man zeigen und
man wird vielleicht auch über beitritt
zur nato sprechen das hilft jetzt im
moment noch nicht aber ein deutlicheres
politisches zeichen für den
schulterschluss europas mit der ukraine
kann man sich eigentlich kaum vorstellen
dass das politische zeichen wie hoch
sind seine erwartungen dass es auch ganz
konkret um waffenlieferungen gehen wird
dass man also auch da nicht mit leeren
händen kommt das ist eigentlich üblich
bei solchen besuchen dass man da
vorbereitungen trifft um ganz klare
sagen zu machen das problem bei der
ganzen geschichte ist tatsächlich die
instandsetzung der waffen die wir
versprochen haben die ausbildung an
diesen waffendeal audi läuft im
augenblick trotzdem gehe ich davon aus
dass nicht im zug jetzt irgendwelche
waffen mitgenommen werden das wäre etwas
naiv aber dass die lieferungen doch
vorankommt und der ukraine ganz klar
unterstützung auf militärischem gebiet
noch einmal zugesagt wird das all das im
großen politischen raum spielt die leute
die aus der ukraine zu uns geflüchtet
sind in ihrer stimmung so stark
beeinträchtigt dass sie sich abgelehnt
fühlen von deutschland das halte ich für
etwas weit hergeholt ich halte es eher
für ein manöver das mit botschaft dass
mal wieder druck zu machen da muss man
dann irgendwann glaube ich auch ein
bisschen unterscheiden die menschen
selbst haben ja auch die aussagen des
botschafters selbst kräftig indem wir
sie gefragt haben und sie auch alle
gesagt haben nein so ist es nicht besten
dank ralf schuler für deine einschätzung
sehr gern